When sire moves us
to the new world,
we're going to need names.
I mean,
89Q12
it's not really a name.
So, I would like my name to be
Lylla.
That's a pretty name, Lylla.
Thank you.
I think my name shall be Teefs,
because although
we all do have them,
mine are definitely
the most prominent.
[laughing]
Teefs.
Lylla.
[laughing]
Me be called Floor
because me is lying on floor.
You’re lying on a floor,
so your name is Floor?
[chuckling]
Yes.
[giggling]
Floor.
What about you, friend?
Someday, I'm going to make
great machines that fly,
And me and my friends
are going to go flying together
into the forever
and beautiful sky.
Lylla and Teefs
and Floor and me.
Rocket.
It really is
good to have friends.
Yeah.